um I just want to talk at the beginning
if I may about the interest rate
decision and because I think that's
going to be something that so many of
our viewers are going to be really
concerned about and we had the comments
of course from the governor of the bank
of England warning us to expect a higher
interest rate Rise um next month what
should we be bracing ourselves to say I
think there's actually been a bit of
misreporting of what Andrew said in
Washington uh yesterday because he was
talking about
um the interest rate decision relative
to what they were expecting back in
August when they did their last monetary
policy report so he wasn't saying
interest rates are going to have to rise
even more than we thought last week
uh really he was just reflecting the
fact that uh the pressures on interest
rates have risen in the past couple
months for reasons we all know uh what's
been happening in Ukraine and the mini
budget
um and he was merely saying to his
audience that they would they would need
to be raising Bank rates so I don't
think people should read anything from
that into their mortgage rates or
anything
uh what is an issue for their mortgage
rates is really what's happening to
Market interest rates they've already
moved up in anticipation of the bank's
future decisions and also reflecting the
turmoil in bond markets which followed
the mini budget the other week I mean
you're talking about the time on the
markets following the mini budget I mean
whenever I have government ministers you
know here in the studio they they try
and really talk about the global forces
which you acknowledge too you know in
Ukraine and the energy prices but it is
correct to say that a lot of this
turmoil is directly caused by the
government policy that we've seen uh yes
I I frankly I think it's disingenuous to
say it's all a global phenomenon it's
not there is a global element if you
look at the general level of interest
rates they've risen by about three
percentage points since the beginning of
the year
um
three quarters of that two-thirds maybe
is the world and what's happening in the
Ukraine but the rest of it is a UK
specific phenomenon and it's
particularly developed since the mini
budget so it's clearly driven by that in
my view and basically we've we've moved
from looking not too dissimilar from the
US or Germany as a a proposition to lend
to to looking more like Italy and Greece
right well that's at all doesn't it
really um what did you make of the new
Chancellor's comments uh yesterday do
you think they would have gone some way
to implicating the market well I I
thought he set the right tone and
importantly he recognized that there are
some difficult decisions ahead he was
going to have to make pretty quickly I
have to say in the next couple of weeks
on both taxes and spending and the
important thing to realize is not simply
just a case of uh changing the identity
of the Chancellor or praying for the
office budget responsibilities report
it's actually the contents and how the
numbers add up
and even before the mini budget in the
medium term there would have been a hole
in the public finances of 30 billion or
so to which the government layered on
another 45 subsequently reduced to
43 billion now they've done a u-turn on
little less than 20 billion of that so
there's still 40 billion they've got to
find from somewhere that's very chunky
so that's why he's right to say there's
some very difficult decisions and The
crucial thing will be whatever
is published in a couple of weeks time
on October the 31st is coherent and that
the market see there is a viable and
plausible plan for making everything fit
together I always feel and that you're
in these kind of political shows you end
up throwing around numbers 40 billion
and it's quite hard to realize what the
enormity of what we're talking about I
mean 40 billion pounds can you put it in
any context kind of you know squeeze
that we'd have to see to fill that Gap
okay well 40 billion is about uh two
percent of annual production of uh the
UK
um I cut in income tax of one percentage
point which is one of the things that
was in the mini budget bringing that
forward one year that costs about five
billion so 40 billion is is quite a lot
if you want to think about it in terms
of uh government spending uh you're
getting on for uh five or six percent
Cuts in government spending and it
should be said uh obviously the
government's talking about you know
efficiency savings and stuff like that
the existing cash limits were set a year
ago when inflation was expected to stay
low uh pay increases in the public
sector were expected to be two or three
percent which is not sustainable now pay
in the private sector is growing at
about seven percent
um so already there is a big squeeze in
real terms on public spending and if
you're going to allow [ __ ]
that has to mean real Cuts you can't
find it from eliminating waste which
will no doubt be the um the Mantra but
there would have to be serious decisions
about things to uh to stop doing serious
decisions including potentially about
the NHS I was interested to read your
comments about you know if you wanted to
get the share of government spendings
GDP down you have to be prepared say to
move away from our own Health Service
free at the point of delivery to one
funded by social insurance uh yeah I
hope that again slightly mischievous
reporting this is part of a long
interview with your economics
correspondent Ed Conway I'll just take
it out with him uh well but but but the
essence of the point that I was making
is that actually the share of government
spending in GDP hasn't changed very much
over 50 years but beneath the surface
there's some very big trends and in
particular the share of health and
spending on uh welfare has risen from
about a quarter of that to half of that
and that larger affects demographics we
have an older population
uh and we've also decided to pay them
better pensions that's going to continue
in the future in the past that was
accommodated by Falling defense spending
falling debt interest spending falling
public capital investment all three of
those elements are programmed to go in
the other way now so it's a challenge
even to hold share of government
spending
constantly make Cuts but to make cuts
and the point that I wanted to stress is
you have to decide actually we want to
do things differently you can't achieve
these things simply by finding a billion
here a billion there
um
I think we are
in in terms of the
um indicators the economy is pretty much
flat lightning to slightly Contracting
looking forward I think it's pretty
inevitable that there will need to be a
period of uh of contraction how big we
don't know but in some sense there needs
to be because the labor market is very
tight vacancies are still at a very high
level and that reflects the fact that
half a million people left the workforce
as a result of the pandemic and if we
see a squeeze in public spending in the
fiscal tightening could that make the
recession more difficult longer well if
you have a tighter fiscal position that
tends to mean lower demand uh lower
output but there's an offset to that
because the bank of England can then run
a looser monetary policy so it's the
flip side what we saw with the mini
budget so the mini budget was basically
something that was going to expand email
on
but in order for the bank of England to
meet its inflation Target it had to
offset the consequences of that by uh
prospectively raising bank rate more so
you can change the mix but the overall
level of demand has to be consistent
with the economy's supply capacity
um just finally we'll have Andrew
Griffith on the show a little later uh
here's one of the few people too have
survived in the Treasury under quasi
Quantum and also the new Chancellor
Jeremy Hunt what would you ask him what
would you like to find out
well I would like to find out what their
plan is for essentially if you like
making the numbers add up in the medium
term so given that they want to have the
ratio of debt to GDP falling
four or five years out presumably uh
what is the balance they're going to
strike between raising taxes or cutting
government spending and if the latter
uh how they were expecting to achieve it
yeah that is the big question uh indeed
thank you so much you're very welcome a
pleasure to have you on the program